grainer es libre así lo confirmó el
presidente estadounidense Joe biden
escoltado por la esposa de kriner su
vicepresidenta y el secretario de estado
hace un momento junto a su esposa
sherell en la oficina oval hablé con
Britney wriner está a salvo está en un
avión está camino a casa
grainer campeona olímpica de baloncesto
fue detenida en Rusia el pasado mes de
febrero por tener aceite de Cannabis en
su equipaje al entrar a ese territorio
en agosto fue condenada a nueve años de
cárcel por Contrabando y posesión de
drogas Estados Unidos ahora enfoca sus
esfuerzos en la liberación de Paul
William un exmarin acusado de espionaje
también arrestado en la nación
euroasiática el pasado 2018 después de
meses de detención injusta en Rusia
Britney binner está de camino a casa con
su esposa cherrell y otros de sus seres
queridos nos estaremos en nuestros
esfuerzos hasta que Paul William también
regrese con su familia Britney fue
intercambiada por quien era considerado
uno los hombres más buscados del mundo
el ciudadano ruso Víctor void un
Traficante de armas conocido como el
mercader de la muerte